our question asks us what equation
describes the growth pattern of this
sequence of blocks so we want to figure
out if i know that x is equal to 10 how
many blocks am i going to have so let's
just look at this pattern here so our
first term in our sequence or our first
object or our first pattern of blocks
right here we just have one block right
there so let me write the term
right up here
so i have the term
and that term
and then i'll have the number of blocks
number
of
blocks
number of blocks so in our first term
we had one block and then our second
term i'll just write this down just so
we have it what happened here so it
looks just like our first term but we
added a column here four blocks so it's
like 1 plus 4 right there so we're going
to have 5 blocks right there we added 4
to it then in our third term what
happened
what happened in our third term well it
just looks just like the second term but
we added another column of 4 blocks here
right we added this column right there
if you imagine they're being added to
the left hand side of the pattern so we
added four more blocks we have nine
blocks now
we have nine blocks so it looks like
each time we're writing four blocks and
on this fourth term same thing the third
term is just this right here
this right here is what the third term
looked like and then we added another
column of four blocks right here so we
added four more so we're going to have
13 blocks so our fourth term
is
13. so let's see if we can come up with
a formula either looking at the the
graphics or maybe looking at the numbers
themselves
so one way to think about it
so we start off with so when x is equal
to 1 let's say that x is equal to
the term
we add just this 1 there then when x is
equal to 2 we added 1 column
of 4. so this is when x is equal to 2.
we have 1 column of 4. then when x is
equal to 3 we have 2 columns of
4 right there and you could even say
when x is equal to 1 you had 0 columns
right we had no nothing no extra just
columns of 4 blocks we didn't have any
and then when x is equal to 4
we had 3 columns
we had three columns there when x is
equal to four so what's a pattern here
or how can we express the number of
blocks we're going to have
given the term that we have
well it looks like we're always going to
have one box so let me write it this way
if i write the number of blocks let me
write it this way number
number
of
the block of blocks
it looks like we're always going to have
one right we have this one right here
that one right there that one right
there that one right there it looks like
we always have one
plus
a certain number of columns of four but
how many columns do we have when x is
equal to one we have no columns of four
blocks when x is equal to two we have
one column when x is equal to three we
have two columns so when x is equal to
anything it looks like we have one less
number of columns so
it's going to be x
it's going to be x minus 1
right when x is 2 x minus 1 is 1 when x
is 3 x minus 1. so this right here is x
minus 1. x is 2 this is x minus 1 this
is x minus 1. this is x minus 1 and x
minus 1 will tell us the number of
columns we have right here we have one
two three columns here we have one two
columns here we only have one column
here we have zero columns so it even
works for the first term and in every
one of these columns so this right here
x minus 1 is the number
of
the number of columns
and then in each column we have four
blocks so it's the number of columns
times
times four right for each of these
columns we have one column we have one
two three four blocks so this is the
equation that describes the growth
pattern so let me write this let me
simplify this a little bit if i were to
multiply 4 times x minus 1 i get the
number of blocks being equal to 1 plus 4
times x i have to distribute it 4 times
x is
4 x and then 4 times negative 1
is
negative 4. so that's equal to the
number
of blocks
the number of blocks and then we could
simplify this we have a 1 and we have a
minus 4 or i guess we're subtracting 4
from it so this is going to be equal to
4 x minus 3 is the number of blocks
given our x terms if we if we're on term
50 it's going to be 4 times 50 which is
200 minus 3 which is 197 blocks now
another way you could have done it is
you could have just said look every time
we're adding 4 this is a linear
relationship and you could essentially
find the the the slope of the line that
connects this but assume that our line
is only defined on integers and that
might be a little bit more complicated
but the way that you think about it is
the way that you think about it is
every one every time we added a block
we added or every time we added a term
we added 4 blocks we could write it this
way we could write change so this
triangle right here means change delta
means change in blocks
change in blocks
change in blocks divided by
divided by change in x now you might
recognize this this is slope so and if
you don't worry you know if you don't if
slope is a completely foreign concept to
you you could just do it the way we did
the first part of this video and that's
a completely legitimate way and
hopefully it'll make some connections
between what slope is
so what is the change in blocks for
change in x so when we went from
x going from
one to two so our change in x here would
be two minus one we increased by one
what was our change in blocks it would
be at four or five minus one
it's 5 minus 1. and what does this equal
to this is equal to
over 1 which is equal to 4. let me
scroll over a little bit so our change
in blocks for change in x is 4 our slope
is equal to 4. so if you want to do this
kind of the setting up a line the
equation of a line way you would say
that our equation if if well let me
write number of blocks number of blocks
are going to be equal to four
times our
four times the the term that we're
dealing with the you know the the term
in our pattern
plus
some constant this right here is the
equation of a line if it's completely
foreign to you just do it the way we did
it earlier in the video
and so how do we solve for this constant
well we use one of our terms here we
know that when we had one in our first
term we only had one block so let's put
that here so in our first term
so when on our first term we're gonna
have that b right there we only had one
block so we have one is equal to four
plus b if you subtract 4 from both sides
of this equation
so you subtract 4 from both sides what
do you get on the left hand side 1 minus
is negative 3 and that's equal to these
fours cancel out
and that's equal to b so another way to
get the equation of line we've just
solved that b is equal to negative three
we said how much do the ch blocks the
number of blocks change for a certain
change in x which is a change in the
number of blocks for a change in x we
saw it's always four four per change in
x when x changes by one we change by
four that gave us our slope and then to
solve for if you view this as a line
although this is only defined on
integers
non i guess positive integers
in this situation you could do this as a
y intercept to solve for this constant
we just use one of our terms you could
have used any of them we used one and
one you could use three and nine you
could use anything we solved b is equal
to negative three and so if you put b
back here you get four x minus three
which is what we got
earlier in the video right there
hopefully you found that fun